welcome to this video playing roller
roller from Denmark many Danish
opponents the iPlayer lots of guys from
from from Miss Scandinavia Denmark's
Sweden and so on okay let's do something
different not the same ish all the time
okay reach is supposed to to a Queens
gambit type of position okay that's a
bit surprising black normally place with
with the c5 in this in this type of line
with Bishop boom to be 40 came yeah okay
play Bishop g4 which is also interesting
i'm not sure does he really want to take
on f3 and doesn't but now I can't play
Knight e5 isn't this good asking this
bishop what is what he is doing a 97 as
an additional idea okay let's let's do
this f4 yeah this is the so-called
pillsbury information named after the
American grand master Harry Nelson
Pillsbury he was a very strong player
not a grandmaster back then they didn't
have the title I'm very strong player
dumb at the turning of the nineteenth
and twentieth century he had some
excellent results but then he is stopped
playing not quite sure why stop playing
was there some health issue not not
quite sure he was an excellent player he
had wins against Lasker and
and very very good player yeah f for
this is supporting the light only five
and it asks black an important question
what are you doing about the idea to
play at five winning a piece and in fact
this is not easy to answer I don't
really see it at the moment how is going
to prevent that sorry besides the fact
that it secures white an excellent space
advantage ok our this is something that
you can do to avoid immediate material
loss I'll just continue to build up ok
retreating now looky one just playing
the normal strengthening moves that you
play in this type of position yeah one
way to control this is cool just
retreated is he preparing 97 and maybe
yeah one way to play is to prepare
g-form at the moment I'm ahead on the
clock and I'm trying to preserve that
it's just come to be at the head there
for once yeah King h1 is possibly
preparing g4 ok yeah this is some always
a question I don't I don't want to
exchange them play Bishop g3 keep more
pieces on the board Wow
yeah so much for you don't want to
exchange how do I avoid it now I guess I
don't
mmm I don't really want to invite the
Queen yeah okay but I have this move
this is important at least not exchange
everything off and now I want to I want
to push this the night back of course
age freaking g1 or something else yeah
it's hard to do without I need to push
it back and if the night retreats to
have six I go 95 again
Bishop H force interesting defensiveness
yeah what you notice that at the moment
the the player pool to play against the
sum is a bit weaker than usual one
reason for that is that I'm recording
this during the European individual
championship which is taking place in
numb in Yerevan in Armenia I think if
i'm not mistaken and what is he doing
see disconnected on no no it's not
disconnected it's taking place in yellow
one and there many strong players so
players who probably play on the ice see
in other cases are not online mm-hmm
what is this yeah good you don't know
sometimes stuff happens your doorbell
rings you get your pizza delivered it
all happened to me then you simply and
don't have much choice you need to leave
the desk and your good time runs out
yeah he loses this sometime
black4 fits on time yeah okay I'm no
idea what was happening them i'm not
sure if i should upload this but maybe i
should because of this set up with that
form this is in fact something that is
very useful to remember it's simply am a
good a good plan in this position type
to establish this night only five it's a
very strong piece and you can build up
behind that this was a good defense
really maybe i should just take now only
seven I didn't really took that into
account that's a good defense yeah right
here in this position um yeah white
still maintains some advantage but it's
not it's not like blackest is lost he he
lost much time with the moving same
piece of twice and who in for the third
time but it's not it's not a disaster
yet he can he can retreat him and
continue from there but okay I have f5
this strong actually intending this
trapping the Queen interesting yeah
maybe you should play a five just
shutting this down and tending putting
the night here I also have this square
of course yeah would have been
interesting still but maybe he got
called away from the desk it it happens
it's not necessarily unfair behavior or
something alright thanks for watching